bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
aujourd'hui dans notre série les grands
champions de l'histoire du jeu d'échecs
nous allons parler de vladimir kramnik
avec jérôme au français jérôme cellier
stéphane alors kramnik champion du monde
de la lignée classique puisque en 2000
d'ailleurs sous le sous les caméras de
bfm tv il remporte le titre mondial en
battant le king
garry kasparov oui il a eu
l'extraordinaire honneur de mettre fin
aux 15 ans brain de garry kasparov tu
restes garry kasparov avait annoncé dès
le début des années 90 quinze jours gras
munich serait champion du monde il a été
sinon exaucé dans ses voeux en tout cas
sa prophétie s'est réalisée comme dick a
bien été champion du monde en 2000 on a
dit l'autre pendant longtemps d'ailleurs
que cramique avait été l'élève de
kasparov je crois qu'il a été rentrée
dans son école d'un sont ils avaient été
un peu fort mais la gravité autour de
kasparov puisqu'il faisait partie de son
équipe de second dans la rue le match de
95 à new york contre allende
donc j'imagine que chronique est tirée
quand même profit du voisinage de
kasparov des préparations qui ont eu
lieu pour ce championnat du monde
par ailleurs chronique a plutôt suivi
l'école beau de binic
il a eu le parcours très classique du
joueur du joueur russe du jeune joueur
soviétique n'est en 75
il apprend à jouer aux échecs à 5 ans à
11 ans il rentre à l'école de binic et à
16 ans il devient grand maître
international sans même avoir le titre
de maître international il a directement
fait d'énormes de grands maîtres tout de
suite 8 ce qui est rarissime - qui sont
ça que ce soit arrivé là même pas été
maître il est devenu directement grand
maître c'est pas mal c'est un petit peu
comme avoir l'agrégation sans avoir le
bac c'est un petit peu étonnant alors
pas pendant longtemps cramique a trusté
les premières places mondiales
avant d'arriver à ce match de l'an 2000
puisque dès les années 80 dès le début
des années 90 il est déjà considéré
comme un prétendant au titre mondial il
fait partie des dix meilleurs du monde
très vite et pendant dix ans il m'est
resté oui déjà numéro 4 au classement en
1991-92 très très jeune il fait figure
de futur grand mais cette maturation va
être un petit peu un petit peu longue
il va s'illustrer notamment et surtout
en gagnant les plus grands tournois
linarès tilburgh monaco dortmund dans
les années 90 mais faut vraiment
attendre 2000 pour que ta ble ment une
entre dans le cercle très fermé des
grands champions qui sont ceux qui ont
réussi en match à devenir champion du
monde
et puis son titre de 2000 a une
légitimité toute particulière puisque
c'est contre garry kasparov
donc personne ne peut venir contester ça
après coup quoi c'est oui c'est le seul
match en un contre un peu kasparov et
jamais perdu c'est là c'est la première
fois qu'ils perdaient si un match même
des matches exhibition mprd pas donc
c'est le seul match avec celui qui ne
s'est pas terminée
les cards off où il était mené 5 3 qui a
été interrompue oui parce que trop long
mais voilà c'est les deux seuls moments
où j'espère on a été battus en match
donc ça quand même une signification
très particulière et ça montre la force
de chroniques et notamment sa capacité à
construire des positions solides contre
lesquels kasparov a eu du mal à passer
même il n'est pas passé du tout ni ce
que faire remarquable et il est devenu
champion du monde sans perte de partie
contre kas par oh oui c'est à dire qu'il
ya le match 2-0 à l'ombre est
effectivement hyper aucune partie alors
à noter dans l'évolution de kramis bon
d'abord c'est un joueur qui arrive qu'un
finalement l'urss s'est éclatée
quasiment déjà
donc c'est un joueur qui n'est plus
soviétique mais vraiment mais russe et
ensuite au niveau 2
de son jeu il ya eu quand même une
évolution faut noter puisque aux
débutants comme aux débuts des années 90
et jusqu'à la fin il jouait encore des
positions plutôt tranchant réseau
dynamique et puis c'est sévère la faune
clément qui s'est mis à jouer des
positions beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
profond de beaucoup plus positionnelle
un peu à la karpov et c'est peut-être
grâce à ça qu'il a réussi à battre
kasparov parce que finalement un contre
kasparov dans ce match on a surtout noté
une sorte de granit chronique et un est
passable et alors que kasparov continuer
à jouer son style de jeu plutôt agressif
etc
il s'est heurté à des conceptions
nouvelles et profonde parce que il nous
a joué quand même la fameuse défense de
berlin qui était une nouveauté en tant
que parties à jouer dans un championnat
du monde c'est la première fois que
cette ouverture je crois devait jouer
peut-être à la limite ce tennis
peut-être fin 19e à vérifier a pu jouer
ça mais est dans l'ère moderne c'était
la première fois qu'on va jouer dans une
partie de cette importance défense voilà
oublié et depuis qu'elle est devenue une
défense super à la mode c'est à dire que
après c'est devenu comme toujours en
elle quand ça a du succès en championnat
du monde
les grands maîtres se disent tiens c'est
jouable et c'était très intéressés à ce
niveau là parce que c'était une défense
extrêmement curieuse tout à fait hors
des schémas traditionnels ou les noirs
se mettent à priori dans une position
assez assez assez mauvaise finalement
avec des pions doubles etc
et puis les kasmas phare rien trouvé
pour essayer de passer ça malgré tout
c'est en fait il servait il s'avère que
c'est une position extrêmement solide
ses loyers une évolution dans le style
de kram dit qu'il était peut-être plus
un joueur de tournois dans les années 90
et pour remporter des matches il faut
aussi c'est à dire apprendre à faire des
parties nulles mais c'est une partie de
l'héritage de petrossian aussi il faut
savoir il faut savoir ne pas perdre deux
parties parce qu'autant il est très
important de gagner des parties dans les
tournois autant faire match nul en
championnat d'une bonne partie du
championnat du monde c'est un résultat
neutre si ça n'affecte en rien le
classement du joueur tout à fait qu' il
a neutralisé kasparov il a réussi à
obtenir les parties nulles dans toutes
les situations qui était un petit peu
compliqué et il a frappé les deux fois
où c'était nécessaire ou l'ouverture
s'est présenté il vait emporté 2 0 alors
autre chose qui caractérise la carrière
de kramis qui n'est pas fini il est
toujours bien sûr une activité mais il a
perdu son titre de champion du monde
ce qui caractérise aussi sa carrière par
rapport à ce titre quand même un peu
particulier c'est qu'il arrive en pleine
il est toujours on est toujours en
scission des titres mondiaux il ya un
championnat du monde fis d'aînés qui
n'est pas aussi reconnu que le
championnat du monde classique que
kasparov tant bien que mal arrive
toujours à organiser short en 93
anne en 95 et finalement au bout de cinq
ans
oui parce qu'il y avait eu d un cycle
des candidats qui avaient été organisées
et c'est alexis shirov qui devait voilà
être le challenger c'est là où je
voulais en venir c'est que finalement
c'est shirov qui devait jouer kasparov
il avait battu crânerie cancer et
finalement on se retrouve quand même un
mec comme à sky sports chronique pour
des raisons de sponsoring en fait même
si les joueurs n'ont pas réussi à
s'entendre sur les conditions le match
avec shirov a capoté comme ça peut
arriver dans le monde de la boxe ou si
je crois que j'ai refusé des offres
c'est à dire que les refuser il y avait
des offres possibles notamment en
californie
kasparov était a priori pour il avait
dans mon à celle d'accepter et
gyrophares refusé sans doute essayer de
faire monter les prix et aux finales b
faillite
finalement cramique et le choix du
prince
c'est le fait du prince puisque c'est
garry kasparov qui décide que son
challenger sera l'a dit mercredi qu'un
donc à l'ancienne en fait à l'ancienne
il se désigne lui-même son challenger
bon c'était peut-être une façon il a
senti que c'est peut-être le moment de
passer le témoin puisque lui même avait
prédit qu'un jour chronique sera
champion du monde donc il s'est lui même
choisi un adversaire à sa mesure
c'est pour ça que certains ont contesté
aussi la tenue de ce match mais la
victoire est la légitimité de chroniques
ne font aucun doute
d'ailleurs les restes et les champions
du monde jusqu'en jusqu'en 2007 et la
réunification du titre qui s'est faite
aux mexicains dans un tournoi à 8 oui a
remporté allant de l'indien oui alors à
noter d'ailleurs que de ce point de vue
la chronique a fait faire quand même une
avancée dans la réunification des titres
effectivement c'est le champion du monde
classique qui a permis finalement que
cette scission b aboutissent à un terme
qu'on en finisse avec avec ce double
titre de champion il défend quand elle
son titre une première fois contre les
co oui donc ça c'est un point important
et il le défend contre topalov aussi oui
ça c'est important dans un alors le
match construit c'est là c'est là que la
réunification se fait en fait bien sûr
le match contre les qu il se déroulera
en 2006 en suisse en syrie
et ça se termine par un match nul les
cours un style très défensif chronique
ne prend pas trop de risque et à
l'infinitif on aboutit au match nul qui
permet à chronique de garder le titre
puisque la règle stipule que le champion
en titre
car le titre en cas de match nul le
match contre topalov était plus tendue
notamment le watergate et voilà temps
illégalité temps il est gay puisque il
topalov s'est plaint que vladimir g
dames il faut expliquer l'histoire il
est gentil c'est quand même très
important le taux le guette c'est l'art
en fête de finhan le scandale des
toilettes
disons les choses telles qu'elles sont
puisque on est en pleine période 2000
donc 2006 par là bon les ordinateurs
tournent à fond et savent très bien
analysé des positions et parfois trouve
des coûts que les champions ne voit pas
eux-mêmes et bien
topalov est soupçonné de tricherie en
fait puisqu'on voit son entraîneur dana
love c'est ça dont on le soupçonne de
donner des indications à son joueur
pendant les tournois il ya déjà des
suspicions de tournon topaloff est
bizarrement ce qui se passe dans ce
tournoi dans ce championnat du monde
c'est kramnik qui est accusé par le camp
de topalov peut-être habitués à ça et
c'est pas mais d'avoir dans les
toilettes
ac c'est finalement à l'impression dans
une ambiance un peu fischer oui c'est
rien pour schizophrénie et on a
l'impression qu'ils aient donc ils
l'accusent de d'être de passer trop de
temps aux toilettes et d'éventuellement
d'avoir accès à des analyses par rinat
heures elle est trop souvent d'utiliser
peut-être un petit ordinateur ou un des
premiers téléphones puisque maintenant
on peut faire tourner un ordinateur
logiciel sur un smartphone c'est pas
c'est pas un souci maintenant que en
tout cas un moyen électronique de
tricher de d'abord des indications avoir
des indications topalov accuse chronique
de sa notamment dans la sphère fait
pschitt
mais pas si chip pas si mal que ça
laisse une trace mois là mais ça
n'empêche pas la chronique de garder le
titre de champion du monde
oui on sait par ailleurs que c'est pas
la première fois ni la dernière fois que
les soupçons de tricherie il ya eu des
tricheries avérées
oui tout à fait il ya toujours des sous
je crois qu'il est quand même toujours
destruction sur le jeu de topalov de ces
années là qu'était où il avait c'est
vrai qu'il avait monté brusquement
niveau quand ils ont bon bref c'était un
peu bizarre enfin le don est de toute
façon c'est un excellent joueur c'est un
très bon joueur
non pas il n'a pas atteint de vaud le
même niveau de performance depuis
non mais c'est un peu bizarre ce qui
s'est passé donc on n'en sait pas plus
mais en tout cas voilà ce qui s'est
passé vraiment il ya eu cette accusation
il ya eu ces suspicions chez crown mais
aussi chez topalov et des histoires
comme ça de dead est d'ailleurs ce type
d'histoire en tendance à avoir lieu dans
d'autres tournois avec d'autres joueurs
par la suite donc kramnik défense en
titre et puis finalement c'est lors du
match fut celle match face à un homme
qui perd en fait est un tournant à ce
tournoi ainsi qu'un tournant mexique
dont à 8 ce qui remportait par parlant
d' un petit peu comment 48 on avait fait
un tournoi ian thomas d'origine celte la
réunification pour les champions du
monde filet et là le champion du monde
ainsi que les meilleurs joueurs des cas
les meilleurs joueurs etc
voilà donc et c'est à nantes finalement
qui prend le titre à chronique équipe
désormais le détient voilà donc sans
l'accord de chroniques pour faire cette
réunification et l'europe a eu lieu dont
il a accepté de le faire peut-être tout
simplement je pense aussi que chronique
n'avait pas l'énergie de kasparov pour
aller lui même chercher des sponsors et
organiser les matchs circle k stores se
voulait à la fois organisateurs et
joueurs ce qui demande énormément
d'énergie n'en avait les chroniques et
plus
un joueur vraiment qui s'intéresse
vraiment qu'au jeu et pas tellement à ce
qui se trame autour et donc ça le
fatigue et un peu sans doute d'essayer
comme ça de trouver des solutions pour
organiser ses matches et donc voilà on
va voir quelques images donc de bladimir
cramique voilà ici alors ça c'est
kramnik à ces jeunes il est déjà très
fort un oui il doit avoir doit avoir 18
19 ans il est déjà parmi les meilleurs
mondiaux malo texen géant il est très
grand et gifi compliqué je sais pas
quelle taille fait je vais pas aller
trop grand je pense moi il fait un mètre
quatre-vingt-dix facile 90 pour jouer au
basket
donc voilà ici encore la chronique un
peu plus tard avec ses lunettes
on reconnaît davantage et les cheveux
beaucoup plus court ouais ici encore une
photo avec toujours chronique en cra va
toujours bien habillé toujours toujours
élégant joueurs toujours élégant à la de
près un super portrait ça c'est pas mal
ça c'est presque dommage qu'on voit pas
et si fier dans la lunetterie
mais là on voit bien qui est en train de
réfléchir oui voila je sais pas combien
d'autres photos à oui alors ça c'est
avec danièle gilbert c'est à dire que
elle ressemble beaucoup
la présentatrice jouer le premier coup
pour un rognon les rares médias et à
gauche voilà c'est alors photo et pas
mal parce qu'on voit énormément de
public beaucoup de beaucoup de
photographes
ce sont les olympiades de dresde ouais
sont déroulées en 2008 et en fait c'est
pas daniel gilbert sais pas d'ailleurs
il faut dire la vérité signalement et
voilà c'est l'adjointe au maire de
dresde tout simplement honorer de sa
présence la la compétition et joue le
premier coup virtuel comme ça se fait
souvent bien sûr la demande et à rognan
ce qu'il fallait jouer il ya 10 pouces
et le pion en d4 l'a fait pour les
photographes on voit qu'ils sont assez
nombreux il ya beaucoup de public
l'allemagne a une tradition de 2
de jeu de manière générale et a beaucoup
de licenciés beaucoup de spectateurs
donc il ya toujours du public en
allemagne pour les grands événements
échiquier alors donc kramnik is it à
droite mais si on le voit avec ses
lunettes et alors à gauche en face de
lui avec les pièces blanches évidemment
voix à rognan qui est un joueur
extraordinaire d'arménie donc
et qui est très très fort qui a fait
partie je sais pas s'il n'a pas été un
moment donné numéro un mondial aussi si
je suis pas si la patronne stella au
classement oui c'est possible ou tout
près on est au près ou s'il a passé un
an ou deux parce que maintenant le
classement est beaucoup plus souvent mis
à jour et il est possible qu'ils soient
passés un peu numéro un mondial je crois
bien je suis pas sûr on a vérifié à côté
de lui il ya aussi akopian contre qui
j'ai eu le mérite de jouer c'est à dire
que j'ai pu faire une partie moi même
contre akopian c'était à lyon justement
90 championnats du monde car pour
kasparov et 20 tournois et à l'époque je
ne sais pas par quel hasard
voilà un appariement fort faibles tout
simplement voilà et je ne sais pas je me
suis évidemment écrasé mais j'ai eu le
plaisir d'avoir fait une partie avait 4
obtient alors à copier ou qui a été
d'ailleurs je crois je suis abstenu
monde fis des faudra vérifier parce que
je crois bien si je crois non il tend
finale contre talisman ainsi que moi que
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt la finale
demain à vérifier enfin tours il est
allé assez haut et tout à fait donc
voilà donc les arméniens qui sont très
forts d'ailleurs ils ont gagné
olympiades celle ci d'ailleurs sans
doute je crois que c'était celle ci
qu'ils ont remporté ils ont remporté
devant pièce sur une 4 c'est quoi c'est
la compétition par équipe c'est à dire
c'est par équipes de quatre joueurs qui
rencontre l'autre nation ici en
l'occurrence les russes et puis l'équipe
qui marque le plus de points évidemment
bengale le match en fait et à la fin de
la compétition et c'est un championnat
bien l'équipe voir marquer plus de
points est sacrée championne tanker des
olympiades
un tournant qui a lieu depuis très
longtemps puisque depuis trop longtemps
cette année là on est en août 2012 ce
sont les 40e olympiades
c'est une compétition qui est déjà une
certaine longévité et on voit d'ailleurs
dans l'équipe russe les grands noms
akram nico 1er juillet ce vide l'air au
deuxième grille tchouk au troisième et
qui a été
battu par genband pour le pour la
qualification aux championnats du monde
2012 et iakovenko qui est à plus de 2700
aussi donc on n'a que des super grand
maître et puis en face aussi et c'était
un match au sommet oui en face on a à
revenir en copiant clarifiant ses
ambitions et puis un petrossian mais
c'est pas le champagne mans des années
c'en est un il a trouvé ça veut dire que
c'est alors on a bien les normes et
arminé on est on les reconnaît
facilement
voilà donc encore une photo ici de
vladimir kramnik en pleine réflexion
voilà avec les pièces noires et puis on
revient à notre première photo voilà
donc on va passer maintenant qu'on a vu
donc cette carrière brillante de
vladimir kramnik donc qui bat kasparov
c'est quand même pas rien c'est lui qui
le sait lui qui le destitue et qui garde
son titre
c'est en ces temps quand même c'est
quand même un beau score c'est pas rien
c'est pas rien c'est plus que ce pass
qui par exemple
oui donc on va passer maintenant à la
partie du jour qui est une partie
évidemment de vladimir kramnik qui a les
blancs ici et qui joue en 1996 donc il
est déjà très très fort il fait partie
des trois meilleurs mondiaux facilement
peut-être même il est peut-être déjà
deuxième c'est tout à fait faisable faut
revoir les classements de l'époque
précisément il joue mais face à une
championne qu'on aime beaucoup sur
donald tv puisque c'est la grande judit
polgar qui là aussi à cette époque là
est déjà dans le top 15 mondial et qui
flirte avec le top 10 et qui donne
maille à partir au tout meilleurs jours
de mon or c'est parti avec cabine f3
kelly m6 c4 g6 et après qu'avait laissé
trois fous j'ai cette voie là c'est le
style de judith qui est un peu comme
kasparov et fisher joue aussi des ventes
extrêmement aigu donc ici l'estonienne
ou alors qu'entre 4 elle va jouer la
sicilienne donc elle s est une joueuse
d'attac
dans la lignée des grands joueurs data
qu'elle aime bien mettre la pression aux
tactiques très vite dans la partie
c'est tout à fait son style donc eu
quatre tout ça est bien petit six des
cartes tout cela est normal petit rock
fougueux 2 et 1,5 alors ça c'est
important
les waratahs tout de suite ici au centre
alors on n'a pas peur pour les noirs
d'une prise prise qu'avaient les prend
puisque on pourrait d'abord échangé les
dames une première fois et puis il ya
une menace forte sur le centre blanc on
peut on peut même envisager tout de
suite pourquoi pas calais prend 1,4 avec
le fou voyez qu'ils attaqueraient par
transparence le cavalier centrale il ya
d'autres possibilités pour les noirs
même de faire mieux on peut même jouer
tour 8 on peut laisser les blancs essaie
de se consolider mais au final la
pression est si forte sur le centre
blanc que les blancs du mal à garder le
pion et à équilibrer le jeu ils sont
obligés de nous tarde de le rendre toute
façon donc en général on le prend pas on
joue petit rock qu'à blesser 6 alors qu
a laissé six augmente la pression sur
des quatre faut pas oublier que derrière
en plus on a un footing muscade et on
invite les blancs 1 pouces et des 5 ce
qui peut paraître un peu de paradoxal
mais ça va fixer la structure de pions
et ça va permettre éventuellement noir
de s'attaquer harceler cette structure
de pions pour la faire exploser
voilà avant d'attaquer la structure il
faut s'assurer qu'elles bougent plus
parce que sinon vous savez pas trop
aussi les blancs peuvent prendre dans
l'ansé etc
mais quand les blancs effectivement joué
t5 après cavaliers 7
on a ici deux structures en boîte et
celle ci est celle ci qui ne peuvent pas
bouger alors à noter c'est très
important quand vous avez comme ça des
structures aux deux pions des chaînes
regardées vert ou vue regarde la chaîne
voiliers mais que cette chaîne et
regarde de ce côté là donc les noirs
vont plutôt attaquer de ce côté là parce
qu'ils auront notamment la case f4 comme
soutien et puis ils vont aussi attaqué
la base sans doute de cette chaîne de
pions ici la base pour l'instant étant
leucate donc on va essayer de jouer f5
pour essayer de casser cette cette base
et inversement les blancs eux regardent
plutôt de l'autre côté à une minichaîne
de pions qui pointe vers la dame donc on
va essayer d'attaquer avec les pions et
de casser aussi sa dette pourquoi pas de
jouer ces cinq d'ouvrir et puis en
mettant les pièces lourdes sur la
colonne c'est de pénétrer dans le camp
ennemi
tranquillement de façon à ouvrir des
brèches alors c'est typique de cette
ouverture qu'on a pu voir par ailleurs
dans d'autres émissions n'est banal tv
de moult et moult fois avec plusieurs
analyses alors ici alors c'est
intéressant puisque on est en plein dans
un des apports théoriques important de
vladimir kramnik ici parce que cette
ouverture est indienne jusqu'à cette
époque se jouer beaucoup et y compris
notamment par le très grand garry
kasparov qui a remporté énormément de
victoires avec cette ouverture avec les
noirs les cramique aura inventé dans
cette période là ce qu'on appelle
maintenant la tacc baïonnette
alors c'est que ce qu'il fait là si la
baïonnette c'est le coût des quatre
alors jusqu'ici on hésitait un peu à
jouer le coup bep cap puisque il ya
l'opportunité de jouer à 5
on va montrer la variante est belle et
blanc ne peuvent pas à défendre par à
trois puisque nascar youri prises les
quatre prises en d4 et regarder un
vis-à-vis tout retour donc son coût à 5
semble fort c'est finalement le coup b5
et après quoi ça sera très dur de jouer
c'est sa gouaille et bien que le pion
b46 on a joué c'est surtout pour pouvoir
jouer c'est simple
donc si on fait ça eh bien on se bloque
notamment à prouver s'il n'y a plus
aucun espoir à lendl c'est fini ça on
peut plus attaquer la lame donc on va
être obligé de subir la taxe des noirs
sans rien avoir en échange
donc ça c'est pas une bonne affaire mais
kramnik sur à cinq a inventé une série
de coups extrêmement qui s'avère
finalement extrêmement forte qu'on avait
sans doute mal estimé avant auparavant à
tel point que cette suite de coups a
fini par décourager kasparov lui même de
jouer cette variante en fait kramnik à
inventer school un fou à 3 est en tout
cas la fim et fo à 3 et puis en fait se
fout on joue le rôle de soutien pour
rejouer ces 5 et 6 les doigts reprennent
et bien simplement on reprend du fonds
et bizarrement en fait on a un fou qui
est très bien placé là parce qu'il n'est
pas attaquable
et il peut défendre la pousser ses 5 et
6 les noirs jouent b6 qui paraît normal
parce que sinon ces 5 arrive très vite
on n'a même pas démarré notre attaque
que tout de suite non seulement jouent
ces scènes mais en plus on a un fou qui
va taper sur des six avec le cavalier
qui veut enlever cinq ça fait déjà tout
de suite deux pièces
ça va vite c'est les noirs qui vont
subir ces nord qui vont subir et si on
joue b si ce qui paraît logique
oui mais si je joue b6 on peut se dire
que j'arrête totalement les attaques
c'est possible oui mais en fait non
parce que on joue quand même à quatre et
on va casser la structure par en
attaquant b6 par simplement à cinq et on
va simplement ouvrir la smb cifs qui
devient faible est en fait la table
blanche a déjà démarré alors qu'on n'a
même pas eu le temps ici d'enclencher
une autre contre attaque avec f5
donc ceci commence à être connu c'est à
dire que là je crois que kasparov a déjà
souffert de ça je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
ait pas déjà perdu une partie à ce
moment là en 96 face akrami donc jeudi
pôle gare est au courant de ça mais ça
m'embête parce qu'elle aime bien jouer
cette variante donc elle va inventer ici
autre chose en tout cas essayer autre
chose et elle joue elle pareil elle se
disait finalement l'idée de l'estonienne
c'est de dire si les blancs attaque vite
il faut que les noirs atteindre vite
aussi donc elle joue très vite le coup
car il y avait cinq c'est quoi l'idée
mais c'est toujours pareil c'est de
préparer f5
parfois on met le cavalier 1,8 mais sans
doute elle joue plus agressif judith ça
c'est son truc à la miaj moins passifs
parce que elle veut peut-être aussi plus
tard le maître un f4 ce cavalier
pourquoi pas on n'a pas peur d'une prise
de fou parce que ça ouvrirait avec le
pion et le fou g7 devient énorme mais
maintenant que beckett a été jouée le
cavalier c3 est en l'air il n'est pas
protégé est juste derrière lui dans
l'enfilade il ya la torah
ce serait dangereux de laisser le pion
5 s'est changé en quatre ans exactement
donc la regarder quand la finesse de
chroniques alors là on est en plein dans
les préparations des très grands joueurs
dans les grands maîtres
tout ça n'est pas le fruit d'une
réflexion sur l'échiquier le jour même
ça a été préparée avant donc tout ça est
très précis regarder tous malades
chroniques alors en jouant tout re 1
cramique 1 mais augmente la défense
potentiel avec la tour du point e 4 qui
est un point crucial notamment si les
noirs jouent et 5 millions annoncés pour
faire une pression ici mais aussi se
prépare pourquoi pas là le repli du fou
sur f1 en cas de qualif 4 et ça
permettra de jouer j'ai trois pour
chasser le cavalier leucate et aurait
ensuite pourquoi pas de faire ressortir
le four g2 exactement pour envisager
après effectivement les g3 des foulées
de mai et l'attaquent noir aura du mal
avec une structure plus peut-être un peu
plus solide
enfin voilà en tout cas des possibilités
après il faut voir les coûts exacts ici
bombay jeudi de continuer la raison on
hamm est sûre faut pas qu'elle traîne
parce que les noirs les blancs sont un
coût de 2 très vite de pouvoir pousser
et c'est peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs
que le coût que les chiens qui est bien
parce que la menace qu avec 4 et
peut-être une vraie menace pour prendre
ce fou ou alors forcé les changes du fou
de cattenom ski pas une bonne affaire et
c'est plus actif que cavalia 8 un peu
lent un peu un peu plus solide en termes
défensif mais justement créé en moins de
menaces si on sait bien que le meilleur
défense c'est l'attaqué c'est la taille
en l'occurrence là où les moins bien
placés qui a 25 ans 8 c'est qu'il est
sur la diagonale du food
alors voilà il ya ça évidemment
contrepartie notamment mes chroniques
mais la met l'accent dessus puisqu'il
joue après ce coût est de 5 qui est un
bon coup mission a ajouté ali g 5 alors
multiples avantages de coucal g5 un pouf
j'attaque l5 avec une destruction 20 du
rock noir ce qui serait pas une bonne
nouvelle
deuxième avantage je protège aussi le
pion aux quatre jeux comme ça chez deux
défenseurs sur la case de 4 donc ça peut
être très pratique aussi la prise
pourquoi pas reprendre avec lecavalier
et puis j'ai un cavalier qui peut
remplacer j'ai un magnifique bocker
c'est très difficile de jouer contre ça
avec les noirs et enfin troisième idée
je peux venir aussi sur la case de 6
créer une multiple fourchette
multi-pièces voilà et ça oblige la
plupart du temps les noirs à se séparer
de leurs fous s'éviter or si on connaît
un peu l'estonienne on sait que ce fou
en général est très bien placé en suite
et que son idée de ce fou c'est de
sortir pour faire maths à la fin de la
variante c'est à la fin de la fin de l'
attaque je mate c'est pas la fin de la
fois le touch c'est la fin de la tâche
du mat et c'est lui qui m'a tant général
c'est l'huile et paix absolue des noirs
donc on n'aime pas trop de voir le
rendre contre un cavalier aussi c'est
quand c'est possible pour les blancs
c'est souvent pas une mauvaise affaire
alors faut calculer son affaire il
s'agit pas non plus de le jouer
n'importe comment ce coup cavaliers
aussi si on prend et de perdre après
ceux qui ont eu six isolés ici pour rien
donc s'en prenant aux six avec le pion
des cinq les blancs se crée aussi une
case pour leurs cavaliers ont des
syndicats
voilà dans ce type de manoeuvre c'est
que quand le effectivement le pion
effectivement bien là le cavalier a pris
peut sauter sur une magnifique à 100 des
5 et c'est toujours extrêmement pénibles
pour les noirs donc tout ça est très bon
pour le cavalier g5 et au cou
thématiques alors du coup bah déjà la
première menace c'est quand même de
casser le rock ici un prises puis on
prend et puis on la position du roi noir
et quand même pas folichonne donc
cavalier f6 de la part de judith qui
revient et si ce qui revient à l'europe
pourquoi pas cavalier de 4 à la limite
on aurait pu envisager qu'ils avaient
défait 4-1 aussi peut-être encore plus
agressif puisque cavaliers f4 alors
attaque faut 2 et sur un coup comme fou
en f1 par exemple qu'il serait possible
on peut menacer g3 réouvert le cavalier
il pourrait revenir en 1 124 pourquoi
pas parce qu'on n'a pas trop peur de fou
prend cavaliers à cause de pions prend
et puis c'est nous qui menace ce sont
des choses sur la grande diagonale avec
du jeu parce que ce pur f4 et pas
vraiment doublé à tout moment le pion f5
pourra s'échanger contre le pied un
cadre soit parce que les blancs prennent
et on reprend soit parce que nous même
on prend donc ce serait c'est un coût
tout à fait envisageable 112 plus actif
que le coup cabaye f6 de judith un peu
plus défensif peut-être un peu plus
passifs mais plus standard aussi on
continue la pression sur quatre on veut
forcer les blancs à prendre un f5 et
pourquoi pas reprendre à le plonger
avoir une forte mobilité de deux pions
ici au centre toujours extrêmement fort
donc ici kramnik joue positionnelle très
très bien il a parfaitement compris
kramnik l'esprit de l'est staline pour
les blancs dans cette position et je
vous fais 3 alors faut s 3 l'idée c'est
de surprotéger la case de 4 qui est une
case clé si les noirs prennent et bien
il faut pouvoir reprendre une pièce et
bloquer toute tentative de bouger ce
pion il faut pas que ce fou se libère si
on arrive à museler ce fou finalement eh
bien on a un peu gagné la partie parce
que ce ne fut obtenue quand il se
réveille il est toujours énorme donc
maintenir absolument un contact et une
protection maximale de la case 2,4 alors
dans cette situation
je lui dit ici jouent le coup droit à
schwyz
alors ça c'est bien parce que ça laisse
aux blancs maintenant alors l'i3 suite
c'est quoi c'est un je m'enlève vous
voyez que comme ici on peut ouvrir le
jeu etc
il peut y avoir plus tard des échecs par
exemple sur les dames b3 plus tard dans
la partie donc c'est ça peut être un
conte prophylactique de moyen long terme
bon c'est un premier point mais surtout
ça libère la casse g8 qui peut être
utile et éventuellement pour une tour
pourquoi pas regarder parce que après
une ouverture f 5 g prend ben ça peut
aider
autre idée c'est que ce cavalier souvent
mal placé on sait où il pas beaucoup de
casse de sortie générale f5 on va
prendre soin du fust du pion pas trop du
cavalier et on peut envisager de mettre
ce cavalier en g8
et puis parfois le cavalier protège ici
la sortie du fou et ce fut finalement
arrive à s'échanger contre le fou noir
des blancs qui est qui est pas mal
c'est une façon finalement de d'activer
aussi le foot le foot italien
même si les grands joueurs estonienne
même pas trop changer ce fou c'est le
foot grünfeld on le garde on préfère le
garder parce que il est à la fin et
finit par se réveiller mais on peut
aussi avoir la fin des parties où il
totalement en mieux rien donc voilà
c'est un coup attentiste aussi 5 ou
prophylactiques et surtout c'est aux
blancs de jouer quoi jouer dutil et
maintenant que les blancs jouent faux b2
et bien c'est l'heure pour les noirs
savent et c'est précis on veut d'abord
ensuite four b2 et maintenant on joue à
donc par rapport à ce qu'on me disait
tout à l'heure avec des fous à 3 et tous
il vous faut à trois on peut hein avec
la même idée de chroniques
elle a perdu un temps on a perdu un
temps c'est dire qu'on a auto été obligé
de jouer four b2 puis il faut à trois
temps dans l'es9 enjoint coup utile qui
évite des échecs ultérieure qui peut
s'avérer vous savez des fois la partie
d'échecs elle se voue à un couperet et
le fait d'avoir joué 2 permettrait là
éventuellement jouer à trois par contre
maintenant alors on n'a plus peur de les
changer en bep cap puisque la tour est
protégée par le flou et par l'ademe dire
c'est vrai on pourrait envisager tout de
suite de jouer
effectivement à trois on n'a pas peur de
prises prise puisque maintenant surtout
reprend en inde par exemple d'en prendre
vous prend donc c'est moins dangereux
mais cramique joue encore différemment
c'est important de voir comment ils
traitent cette position alors ça c'est
un peu étonnant d'un coup un peu
paradoxal puisque on a expliqué tout à
l'heure que c'était ennuyeux pour les
blancs mais il le fait quand on a fermé
le jeu de marine le fait quand même
alors là c'est sa séverine et ni
suffisamment comme ça qu'on devient
champion du monde c'est en respectant
certaines règles mais pas toutes pas
tout alors la baie st louis alors ça
c'est un curieux parce que b 5e kramis
estime que les noirs finalement n'ont
pas vraiment d'attaqué si maintenant
qu'il a joués précisément ses coûts
peut-être que le coût qui avait cartonné
pauline et n'ont pas été joués ça peut
ça peut expliquer que la taxe soit un
peu sont un peu freiné et fut après 1,5
peut-être qu'il a l'idée de maintenant
de jouer messi alors tonné le pion vous
peut jouer messi alors et les noirs
pourrait bloquer en si on bloque ici on
va pas trop qu'on est noirs les blancs
pourrait passer donc c'est à dire que si
en cas de b6 des noirs ici on pourrait
imaginer c'est pas du tout ce que je
vous jure guillemets en cas de b6 des
noirs on sait pas trop comment les
blancs peuvent passer à part de tenter
cavaliers aussi fou prend plus on prend
pour ouvrir le jeu un petit peu mais
c'est vrai ça a l'air que sûrement la
suite le plus le plus agressive ou la
plus porteuse d'espoir de gains voilà
sont tous agressive mais qui quand même
et papa c'est un plat dont on ne voit
pas bien comment pourrait suffire
peut-être que le coût que la vallée des
saints qui suit obligerait une prise et
après la prise du pion sait on se
retrouve avec un pion c7 totalement
arriérés arriérés qui ne peut pas
avancer parce qu'il ya des pions en
bessin qui des cinq qui le prendrais
soin ans et 6 soit en passant si on joue
c'est ça tu as quitté peut-être l'idée
positionnelle on le saura pas puisque je
lui dis tu joues finalement tombé huit
coups mystérieux alors ça c'est un coup
tondez 8 qu'est vraiment alors que si le
coût autour des 8 peut avoir comme idée
ces six mois je vois bien judith jouée
ces six parce qu'elle n'aime pas trop
les positions forcément fermé mais c'est
une joueuse d'attac encore une fois
parce que c'est 600 cas de bay prend b
prend la tour attaque le fou des deux
donc c'est une tentative de m ici un
vis-à-vis tour fou hein pourquoi pas
avec l'idée pourquoi pas des gels douche
c'est cissé puis de provoquer des
échanges au centre mais la chronique que
perd pas de temps il joue cavalier aussi
voilà ça y est tu le fou donc déjà
affaiblis toute attaque ici mais un
petit pion il faut avoir calculé parce
qu'attention soutien est faible aux
siens
il est souvent faible donc il faut faire
attention quand même donc ici fou prend
1,6 des problèmes si nice et voyez là
bon alors ce pion il suffit de jouer
dame c8 et on ne peut pas le protéger
sauf que en fait sur un coup comme
d'assez dame s'est vite on va le tester
ici les blanches vous le couvre très
fort qu'à valider cinq ça suffit puisque
en cas de dame prend le 6 on se venge
sur le pion c7
il avait une autre option plus qu'à
valider cinq ou six et v6 ryan trop
option c'est de jouer b6 effectivement
si la dame prend aussi ce nom prend ses
sept
alors si on en prend 1,6 en fait on
prend ces sept donc le coup logique ici
c'est de jouer sans doute passé six
parce que on perdrait le plan des six
mais tout simplement pions prendre des
six par exemple et dans ce cas là sur
dame prend des six les noirs sont bien
parce que les mêmes cavaliers le set qui
emprise il tend prise mais on peut se
venger d'abord ici et ça libère la case
n 5 qui a pas que la dame
donc ça c'est bien pour le moment fait
ça c'est pas mal par exemple cavalli
prend le 4 on peut faire cavalier
pendant quatre d'abord [ __ ] ans où il
faut penser bien protégé smic et puis on
peut jouer alors soit cavaliers f5
éventuellement mais encore mieux et
encore mieux ces dames ces cinq hommes
6,5 protège à la fois b6 et le cabillaud
7 par transparence
on s'est pas mal pour les noirs
c'est ensuite je pense un petit peu
c'est bon pour les blancs frêle échange
des dames
alors ce qu'il faut changer les dames et
ce qu'il faut jouer fou à trois ans à
l'air encore plus fort oui c'est vrai
que c'est fort pour les pour lui blanc
parce que laure là du coup il ya du
matériel
c'est embêtant mais c'est embêtant c'est
embêtant donc il faut trouver autre
chose donc sur dame s'est vite b6
c'est embêtant donc là il faut peut-être
réagir faut quand même prendre le 6
voilà tout simplement on prend quand
même un os 6 on n'a pas peur de pions
prend ses c'est depuis ce qu'on va jouer
autour c8 et voilà les bleus ne peuvent
pas pas défendre mais il faut activer le
fou en être
par contre alors ouais alors par exemple
si les or si les blancs à noter quand
même si les anges ou kallio 5 on peut
prendre une première fois d'abord à un
cadre par exemple puis jouer cavalier 8
et ça y est on va récupérer le pion on
perd près de celui-là mais c'est pas
grave c'est pas ce qu'on va jouer fou à
tron avec les avec les avec les blancs
mais bon au final si on récupère ce pion
ça va il n'y aura pas trop de souci il
ya du jeu pour les noirs quoi on n'est
pas totalement fou tu donc ici des
prendre 6 alors je dis tu vois tendre
quand même si c'est malin ça ne plaît
pas et finalement les joutes l'aller 8
alors qu'à l'élite cc c'est bien bon
hein ça libère l'action de la tour sur
la colonne f
donc ça permet de d'avoir un peu
d'action avec ses sept tours le cavalier
aussi surtout défend les points
névralgiques
c'est cette lessive donc ça permet
d'envisager la manoeuvre dams évite de
prendre ça c'est bien et la cram igloo
tom b 3 donc d'un b3 coûts de
développement de la dame tranquille
et comme il se presse pas alors
évidemment dab et 3b dont conjonction
avec v6 dont tu parlais tout à l'heure
pourquoi pas ça peut être une idée parce
que si b6 haute des six est quand même
un peu faible protège par transparence
ça peut protéger par transparence ont
aussi le pion du sis dans certaines
variantes on pourrait plus et c5 sa
gagnante en protégeant aussi ce qu'on
pouvait entendre pourrait peut-être même
le plus et tout de suite il pour jouer
dam des 7 derrière
ouais on pouvait tous pouvaient intenter
mais l'idée là dedans bêtement c'est
peut-être de jouer tour a des seins pour
mette un vis-à-vis tour dames sera
forcément désagréable pour les noirs il
ya aussi la possibilité de faire tu
auras d1 avec un vis-à-vis tout à fait
tourner en b3 donc ici alors cranie
comme judith aurait pu quand même tenté
dame s'est vite c'est le coût normal
puisque dame s'est vite encore une fois
c'est toujours pareil hein ce pion est à
la fois un poison pour les noirs parce
qu'on voit bien qu'ils perturbent les
pièces blanches les pièces noires
pendant mes idées c'est aussi facile et
aux faibles aussi c'est clairement
regarder si je joue cavalier des singles
j'attaque le cavalier il suffit de
prendre dame prend 2,6 et c'est fini le
pion c7 maintenant est protégée elle va
tenter je pense que l'idée c'est 5 pour
protéger le pion parce que
dit trop important pour l'autre alors on
peut en débarrasser dès lors c'est
l'idée d'un b3 bien sûr c'est d'avoir ce
qu'on disait c'est qu'on a un oeil sur
six en jouant ses 5 mai ses cinq se
heurte à puis on prend ces cinq alors le
problème de rupture français
s'inquiètent toujours des progrès
beaucoup c'est qu'on affaiblit
maintenant le pion aux 5
il est plus faible bon il est encore
tenue par le fou mais il n'est plus
défendue par d'autres pions et on n'a
toujours pas résolu le problème du pur
réussissent donc regarder maintenant il
suffit de faire un tour à des uns et la
menace d'invasion dans le camp noir tour
el tri concrètes d'envoyer le style de
menaces que que procure dame métro alors
ça explique le coup suivant de judith
ces cinq coups qui est un peu mystérieux
a priori belge empêche ces cinq mais ça
empêche ses seins voilà ce qu'on vient
de voir on empêche ces cinq mais on a un
faible ici c'est toujours pareil à
chaque fois vous bougez un pion vous en
affaiblit c'est un autre ici c'est celle
et le pian des six qui est faible alors
si ce pion des six tombes cela
affaiblira encore le pion eu 5
donc ce n'est jamais agréable alors ici
kramnik voit cette finalement cette
faiblesse et louvre le jeu avec eux
prend 1,5 c'est l'heure il estime que
tout ça finalement c'est faible
il va pouvoir notamment attaqué ceux qui
ont des six qui n'a pas la possibilité
de d'avancé puisqu'il est sous la menace
d'un pion et il ouvre le jeu pour ces
fous ils voient que les pions sans trop
noir sont sur cases noires ils sont fous
sur case blanche
donc il va pouvoir balayer les cases
blanches à sa guise exactement temps que
prend f5
alors ici les noirs auraient dû sans
doute joué le coup cavaliers pro f 5
pourquoi parce que ce coût est toujours
intéressant puisqu'il peut menacer à
terme devenir en d4 avec une magnifique
case qui bouche la faiblesse sur le plan
des six qui est protégé par deux pions
et qui donne un cavani extrêmement forte
le problème étant que s'il ya une
réfutation tactique a calé cinq c'est
qu'on joue tout de suite et sa menace en
cas de cahiers des 4 on va menacer eu
cette attaque dames et tours
aïe ça fait mal alors s'il ya une pièce
oui ça gagne pièce alors pour l'instant
on ne peut pas le faire puisque le
cavalier protège
combien on peut jouer un coup comme eux
mais sur kbc 7 bien sûr mais là par
exemple les blancs peuvent continuer
simplement faisant cavalier prendre d'en
prendre et protéger leurs pions mais si
ça y est il est définitivement protégé
puisque maintenant même si le fouillent
pris un jour ou l'autre il y aura
toujours le pion s'équipent en occupions
va rester un poison pour les noirs donc
c'est ça qui est pénible en fait alors
que le cavalier ici bien pourra toujours
être pris alors cavaliers prend des
quatre sans doute je le prends tout
simplement c'est encore le mieux faut
prendre des 4 et après c'est pas en d4
qui est naturel bilan des courses
d'aller blanc un pion pénible dans le
camp noir tandis que ses pions même
s'ils sont effectivement bien mais ils
peuvent pas avancer insula peut pas
avancer parce qu'il est bien contrôlée
celui-là on n'a pas plus surtout que si
l'argent s'il y avait pris en un seul
coup de toute façon puis le pur sang qui
est un petit peu un peu faible là puis
ont assuré qu'ils iraient de jaude et 6
par exemple pour le couper de la défense
exact du pion bessette et on en ferait
une cible assez rapidement exacte tout à
fait je voulais si ça empêche le pion b
de venir le défendre a jamais il faudra
mobiliser une pièce sa défense bon donc
là les blancs sont mieux là aussi ils
sont un peu mieux donc que prend
obsèques gpra f5 donc judith pour cette
raison préfère prendre du plomb g et au
moins essayer de boucher ce fou et tout
en libérant le sien et la regarder alors
très joli sans doute des jolis coups de
la partie esthétiquement il est beau
c'est pas mal foch 5
on s'y attend pas parce qu'on voit le
fou sur la diagonale
bah oui qui va vers le centre ah oui et
non il vient là mais ce sarine et aux
pions de 6 mais voilà même pas derrière
mais devant et devint salaire il veut il
veut venir se fout en fait ce n'est pas
tel on ne veut pas prendre le cavalier
c'est pas ça l'idée l'idée c'est de
venir sur la case f7 et est protégé par
le fou tout en protégeant protégé par le
pion et tout en protégeant le pion les
deux pièces se défendre et l'une l'autre
avec un énorme poison dans le camp noir
qui empêche toute mobilité des pièces
voilà ça créerait des gros gros soucis
avec pas de possibilité de les virer
facilement 1 c'est très très compliqué
donc je lui dis tu vois ça elle essaye
de s'en sortir avec elle nécessaire
alors évidemment qu'elle et ses sept la
menace elle est simple c'est de venir
prendre le 6 donc fou et 7 maintenant
est quasiment forcé dame s'est vite ça a
l'air bien pour les noirs ça y est c'est
le fameux coup qu'on a différé jusqu'à
présent on a deux pièces qui attaque et
les blancs n'ont pas de coût immédiat
pour défendre mais ils ont un coût
intermédiaire ou un coup de d'attac
caballé des cinq qui finalement défend
indirectement les pions au cices
puisqu'on peut pas le prendre à cause de
cavaliers prendre le set
ce qui est pénible oui et ça fasse force
quasiment les changes
sa force les change quoi faire d'autre
où va le cavalier parce qu'on peut
envisager qui a veillé g6 imaginons
cavaliers g6 par exemple et dans ce cas
là bas simplement on pourrait prendre
angers 6 prises prises et regarder à et
ça fait mal ou le transfert ou échec on
peut pas mettre le fou à cause de dames
pour un check obligé de mettre le fou du
roi j'ai vite et cavaliers eu cet échec
fourchette royal et on prend la dame et
ses mates et ses fourchettes mais il n'y
a même pas la fourchette seimat ya plus
de cases pour le roi lors on ne peut
même pas sortir en f 7 puisqu'il est en
échec et mat en fait c'est ma tante de
quoi
donc attention donc sur quatre des cinq
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi et si
on va en j80 contre cazes essayons de
voir si on vend g8
et bien c'est amusant parce qu'il ya
cavaliers b6 qui est peut-être la donne
il s'était dit suivi de cavaliers 17
avec une fourchette ou sur la dernière
attaque et donc on est obligé de sortir
de l' attaque du pion le site on est
obligé de venir en des 8 et déjà le pion
aussi ses protégés et en plus on a une
fourchette hop c'est horrible à ces
voiliers c'est ce simple pion aux 6
quand même un poison absolue avec
quelques trucs il une menace tous alors
donc sur les allées des singles n'y a
pas le choix faut prendre
voilà donc elle prend depuis du cavaly c
est donc chronique maintenant reprend de
son pion c est ça y est c'est fini ça
c'est définitivement un poison pour les
noirs puisque et bien c'est imprenable
enfin tout se défend là on va être
obligé de faire des sacrifices si on
veut s'en sortir alors judith s'accroche
à lui continue alors sans doute et la
peur ici maintenant que judith du très
fort coup au f4 parce que f4 menace
prise et si on prend du plan on libère
ce pion en rien black et si on prend du
fou on y un sacrifice de qualité qui lui
semble bon bah oui mais alors imaginons
le regarder c'est typique c'est vrai
imaginons que les noirs ou n'importe
quoi à manier un v6 on peut envisager un
f4 d'accord et que font les noirs ici
donc s'il joue un petit coup alors si on
joue qu'est ce qu'on a dit je sais pas
m'en pour on pourrait faire ça par
exemple c'est un peu embêtant damas trop
en attaque les 6/10 la menace est
toujours là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc sur un petit
coup oui allez prendre b5 et simplement
alors ça me prendrait six attaques
depuis le 5 et on pourra encore jouer
ses trois c'est extrêmement tendue ces
trois là bas ou simplement prendre et la
dame prise prise tombé 1 et on a un
problème on ça entre a noté qu' on ne
peut pas prendre parce que et puis il a
menacé cette théorie classique quasiment
obligé de donner la qualité aux rives 7
c'est horrible bon bref
alors donc c'est prendre des cinq donc
f4 notamment en partie pour empêcher le
coup et 4 très certainement et aussi
pourquoi pas pour essayer de donner de
l'air aux cavaliers et bouger un peu
ceci dit qu'elle peut pas partir très
loin parce que le coup et cède peut être
très dangereux au plus tard
chronique a fini son travail sans barça
ça arrive souvent quand le travail est
terminé on s'en va on a on a finalement
le fou est venue défendre le pion mais
maintenant le pion des cinq défend donc
ce fou peut devenir actif ailleurs et
notamment il peut bloquer les cases
blanches ici mais c'est que tous les
pions quatre pions noirs centraux sur 15
me sur 15 morts alors je dis tu joues
des six alors ça c'est bien l'idée bon
effectivement à la fin c'est pourquoi
pas 2 1 très bien défendre ses pions
maintenant en ce sens qu'il plus de
soucis notamment le pion à 5 mais aussi
et surtout de jouer sans doute le tour
le coutour bessette afin de défendre
cette septième rangée et notamment la
case aux sept tours à dire 2,5 attaque
le fou h5 et là regardez vous octroie
dans la folle trois grammy qui veut
mettre ses pièces sur les cases voyez
que c'est les cases opposé des pions
noirs donc c'est les cases de
bloque toute avancée dame g8 ici judith
fidèle à son style d'attaqué c'est de
s'en sortir par une attaque
elle met une dame déjà en bise à vie
elle va vouloir sans doute mettre une
tour pourquoi pas à tenter
cabaye f5 cavaliers h4 avec des menaces
du sacrifice oui ou jouets 3 1 vous
voyez le 3 août à venir en f3 donc là
encore des petites blessures des petites
menaces qui va falloir gérer et kramnik
va devoir jouer précis il faut d'abord
fou 4 à noter que fou et 4 ab libère le
potentiel de la dame pour venir sur les
leroy touché 5 est normal attention il
peut déjà y avoir des menaces de type ah
non même pas il ya le foin je pensais à
tout ranger devra prendre et on sort le
fou ou avec échec bon ceci dit le fou
menace pèse mais il faut commencer à
penser à ce manager tour des 3 donc ça
alors là c'est très bien à la fois une
tour qui s'activent et surtout qui peut
coulisser ça on a déjà parlé plein de
fois sur les gones altérer la
possibilité de coulisses et les tours
sur la troisième rangée donc faux et 6
je suis dit tu continues méthodiquement
à mas et pourquoi pas jouer la dame
pourquoi pas jouer tour g8 et avoir un
deux trois pièces à la table du roi
ça me lasserai tour penchée 2 suivi d'un
math rapide donc il faut faire attention
quand même un mec et blanc bon c
chronique qui l'a vu tout ça il faut
quand même être précis il est mieux du
fait qu'il a cette structure ici dans le
camp adverse mais il faut faire
attention
et puis la meilleure défense c'est
l'attaqué dollars 3,3 twh trois mois
aussi je menace des choses aïe ça fait
mal hein ça revient en objet de donner
la date parce que là ça menace tout
reprend et il n'y a pas d'autre choix
que de donner la dame vous prend et on a
perdu la dame donc il faut protéger par
câble et j'ai 6 ans bloquent l'action du
fou mais
on la liaison entre la dame et la tour
douala ça retarde un peu la taxe à
atteindre la taille mais judith eux se
dit que je vais pouvoir elle va pouvoir
jouer tour bessette et elle va contrôler
ce pion achète en plus c'est dans son
plan puisqu'elle peut mettre la tour
angers7
et ainsi contribuer à la massage des des
pièces lourdes contre le roi et demi la
f3 très bien entre amis que vous voyez
ils perdent pas le nord
il va sur les cases blanches qui sont
les cases contre lesquels les noirs ne
peuvent rien faire fou de quasiment tous
les pions se sont immobilisées sont
quasiment à lecavalier contrôle des
caisses noires on voit pas en plus
comment ils pourraient s'activer pour
contrôler des casques blancs je suis
fort et qui viendra h4 mais c'est pas on
ne voit pas trop comment il pourrait
faire et donc s'il semble là bas ils
contrôlent rien quoi donc d'un f3 très
bien en plus j'ai un petit oeil sur g de
tomber cette c'est ce qu'on disait
regardez quand on sait pas quoi faire
pouf voit la tourache cinq chroniques
voit bien qu'ils aient une petite
attaque noir qui me falloir repousser
pourra tirer avantage de son ceinturon
passer ça il est quand même à 2 2 cases
variés il va falloir qu'il arrive à
casser tout ça mais un matin il peut
échanger des pièces tout reprend h5 d'un
prince s'est jusqu'ici tout est normal
et en feinte tour g7 les pièces noires
sont quasiment à leur maximum de
potentiel ici mais ça but ça but mais
est quand même une vraie menace c'est
caballé h4 ici qui peut menacer
car les projets 2 voire même tour projet
de tout simplement le cavaliere hkd sera
protégé par le fou f6 c'est sans doute
le maximum que pouvaient obtenir les
noirs dans cette position donc ramené
quoi ça il vous j'ai trois mois là il
joue un coup préventif un joueur j'ai
trois balles
quand même ils pointent le fait que les
noirs oui certes ont massé des pièces
mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait contre la
machine g3 ici mais pas grand chose
alors le cavalier peut toujours venir on
h 4 il est le bleu pions g3 est cloué et
ensuite il a plus de cibles il va pas
sauter au g2 pour sacrifier f3 et deux
fois défendu donc mais oui c'est ça il
en vient de faire une fois qu'il n'ya
rien à faire donc ça bloque
j'ai trois chroniques mais met le doigt
sur le problème des noirs c'est que
baisser cet amas cement de pièces
finement nous menace rien parce que les
blancs sont suffisamment bien défendu et
maintenant ça va être à eux deux de
jouer en quelque sorte un cavalier sept
ans libère la force des pièces lourdes
ici mais sa menace rien aux chroniques
prendre son temps pourquoi il jouera
s'il n'y a pas peur de ça en fait c'est
qu'il veut mettre la tour tôt ou tard en
geslin pourquoi pas en g2 défendue par
les après échanger et faire des échanges
de pièces il est mieux dans la finale à
cause toujours de ses pions dans les
fuites dont j'ai fait tranquille
cavaliers g8 de judith qui continue à
essayer de manoeuvrer a essayé d'activer
ces pièces de trouver une meilleure
façon de poursuivre une tentative de
pression sur les lois mais tout
simplement d'un f3 de la part de
chroniques qui revient et gap a peur
dames et trois menaces puis on prend un
f4 et le pion au f4 est perdu ceci près
que la reprise ouvre la diagonale des
fous nous faudrait changer sur deux
précise le pion et nombre et non parce
que prise prise d'armes prend et en cas
de fou prend mais ces dames program will
et donc à une vraie menace
oui il ya une vraie menace ici 2
2 effectivement de prise donc foulé 5 ça
explique le foulée 5 h quatre nouvelles
fou on n'a pas le choix si on veut
garder le contact sur f4e il va falloir
il a rejoint m6 a maintenant il se dit
juste peut se dire maintenant que
jusqu'à traiter jouer en cas de prise je
peux me venger et éventuellement sur le
pion h4 donc tous les deux c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure mais la tour
d'abord en g2 parce qu'on protège la
tour avec les pièces blanches en plus
maintenant on peut envisager pourquoi
pas de mettre la tourache 2 s'il est si
les noirs prennent à quatre ça peut ça
peut être un thème tabou set up pain je
bloque le pion au no 6 et italiens sur
hp at on sait jamais damages cinq
chroniques se presse pas il n'est pas
encore prêt pour la combinaison final il
continue voyez à étouffer toute velléité
noir on empêche même tout sacrifice ici
en h4 et impossibilité de prendre et je
prends g3s plongé trois dames et fuit
voyez que les noirs sont obligés
d'attendre on revient tour f2 alors ça
c'est un pion conséquent je clou le fou
sur la dame est évidemment le coutour
projet 3 n'est pas possible puisque il
ya dame prend h7 matt martin d'amd 8 de
judith voiliers qui est obligé
d'attendre un jour n'est pas encore un
coup d'attentes et là regardez comment
cramique va finir ça c'est très joli
g4 c'est du vent donc j'ai quatre la
menace évidemment c'est de jouer g5 et
le foot obligé de partir la tour
maintenant toute possibilité de venir en
aide cette ce sont les blancs qui
attaque sur france 4 sur faut prendre
quatre évidemment on peut bien sûr
rentrer les recettes avec le taux peut
quand même joué tours fc est ici et puis
il faut pas oublier qu'il ya la menace
d'armes prend h7 tout reprend et
d'autres promettent puisque le fou
protège la case h7
il ya aussi la possibilité de faire
tourner tout roi prend et dame prend à
cet échec aussi bon c'est pas mal mais
c'est quasi maths ça va pas être dur de
trouver un mode dans cette position donc
après g4
on peut dire que là ça y est finalement
les noirs ont eu beau masse et des
pièces finalement leur position est
tellement gêné par voyez ce pion qui à
la fin c'est rossi a pénétré 27 est
tellement gênant les noirs ne peuvent
pas vraiment s'éloigner du bord et la
progression était de toute façon
inefficace était vouée à l'échec parce
que les blancs de toute façon avec
toutes les pièces nécessaires pour la
défense et ont pu petit à petit monter
leurs attaques
donc faut c'est de jeu dit encore un
coup d'attentes elle attend la sentence
g5 g5 empêche toute velléité maintenant
de bouger qu'est ce que je fais et puis
j'ai cinq ça prive le lecavalier f6
j'évite d'aller en justice
en plus je peux plus bouger je peux plus
bouger plus j'ai plus de courriers plus
de coups ça s'appelle un besoin en fait
la preuve c'est que bayrou c'est
carrément c'est clair ça c'est terrible
parce que c'est qu'est-ce que six coups
il va nulle part se fout de toute façon
il sera pris s'il avance donc ce pion
parlons donc tous rêvent cette voie là
c'est mort jeudi de jouer encore un coup
dans huit par dépit et regardez ces
magnifiques pouf abandon damage cet
échec là c'est la fin d'un tour prend à
cette vente
c'est un vrai écrasement positionnelle
un vrai crassement positionnelle c'est
je dis tu abandonnes ici évidemment si
elle prend la tour
la dame pardon elle est obligée de
prendre mais la tour puisque le fou
protège on ne peut pas prendre avec le
roi puisqu'on sera un échec c'est au
besoin de jouer tout reprend échec et
mat
voilà le roi a été étouffée et alors
c'est tout la position noir on lave on
le voit qui a été étouffée voyez comme
les blancs ont finalement bloqué la
structure noire en se donnant un pion
empoisonné dans le camp noir c'est
toujours extrêmement délicat et il est
noir était un peu extrêmement gênée par
ce pion pouvait pas manoeuvrer comme il
voulait et ils ont essayé de monter une
petite attaque allait droit mais au
final on a bien vu que les blancs
n'avaient aucune faiblesse et que ce
pion aux six s'avère bel
le finalement la baïonnette qui permet
l'invasion finale en 9 sets et non
seulement ça a bloqué les noirs mais en
plus c'est ce qui cause leur malheur
finale en dépit d'une réaction parce que
quand on voit les noirs mobilisent leur
force on se dit qu'il va ailleurs contre
attaque réaction chronique à tous
désamorcer tout en maintenant la
pression tout en gardant ses pièces il a
monté son attaque avec prudence
on est dans une position solide et ça a
quelque chose d'assez inéluctable quand
on regarde comme ça et ça mais c'est
vraiment du crown y exercer pour cette
partie c'est pour ça qu'on l'a choisie
elle est vraiment symptomatique du style
de kramnik qui est à la fois extrêmement
précis tactiquement qu'on nous l'avait
vu mais qui augmente petit à petit son
avantage un peu à la carpe au vrai une
partie assez karpunina race et carpeaux
viennent petit à petit jusqu'au jour où
ben ça craque quoi ça finit par craquer
naturellement voilà c'est ont fini sur
ce joli tableau de match final cette
partie pour rendre hommage à la carrière
de vladimir kramnik 14e champion du
monde classique depuis
steinitz en 1886 kramnik a battu
kasparov et qui au final s'est fait
succéder par le champion du monde en
titre en 2012 c'est-à-dire vichy
manhattan allende
merci de nous avoir suivis merci jérôme
ainsi stephen et puis je vous donne
rendez vous sur des gones altéré pour
d'autres émissions sur les grands
champions de l'histoire du fait des
chèques au revoir au revoir